this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
on the 28th of february 2009
russian-american woman natasha varushka
stood in front of a man holding a
clipboard and several other onlookers
she picked up a 58 centimeter long razor
sharp steel
sword tilted her head back and slid the
blade
down her throat until only the hilt was
visible
a moment of disbelief and silence fell
upon the crowd
as the clipboard man quickly scribbled
something
remarkably varushka did not start
vomiting blood
instead she calmly and steadily
pulls the blade back out her stomach up
through her
esophagus and out her mouth
she had just set the official world
record
for the longest sword ever swallowed
in recorded history now 58 centimeters
is a fairly average length for a sword
but not a sword swallowers sword they
typically use much shorter and thinner
blades
to allow them a fighting chance of not
stabbing up their insides
to give you an idea of how incredible
varushka's record-breaking
feat was the length of your average
female esophagus is 22.5 centimeters
meaning 35.5 centimeters of the sword
she swallowed
had to enter parts of the human body
that are
let's just say a lot bendier
now i wouldn't blame you if you think
sword swallowing
as impressive as it looks is just a
visual illusion with
lashings of theater like the old
assistant getting sawn in half inside a
box gimmick but actually
no sword swallowers don't use
collapsible swords
there are no mirrors and usually no
smoke
the steel blades they use are completely
real usually they have rounded edges but
other performers like to use genuinely
razor sharp
swords that could slice through a
watermelon
or vital organs without much effort
i'm so sorry to tell your anxiety but
sword swallowing is very real
and extremely dangerous it's a
remarkable feat
combining human endurance mind over
matter
and years of practice and
as we're about to find out it has a rich
and
wild history never mind sword swallowing
it's time to swallow your fears about
losing your hair
with keeps i've had people close to me
start to lose their hair
as early as their twenties and it's
always been an obsessing experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness
by the time they're 35 but the best
thing you can do to prevent hair loss is
take the initiative
now and do something about it whilst
you've still got hair left
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for a hair loss prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit an
online doctor
and get the medication you need
delivered directly to your door
i like keeps because it makes treatment
super easy by delivering your hair loss
medication
every three months there's a good reason
that keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trusts
them
for their hair loss prevention
medication so
if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair
just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results
and the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash
42 or click the link in the description
below
to receive 50 off your first order
despite the obvious dangers most of the
time sword swallowing goes surprisingly
well
a report by sword swallowers association
international
asked 46 sword swallowers whether they'd
been injured whilst practicing their
craft
most of them unsurprisingly reported
having sore throats
known in the trade as sword throats
many also reported lower chest pain
though apparently this clears up after a
few days of not
ramming several inches of sharp steel
where it shouldn't go
amazing others were a little less
fortunate
16 of the 46 swallowers surveyed
had suffered intestinal bleeding and
free had ended up with serious injuries
that required surgery
in one case the performer claimed to
have been distracted by his sidekick
a nausea parrot perched on his shoulder
resulting in a torn esophagus
another was a belly dancer who while
swallowing three swords at once
lodged all three painfully in her
esophagus
after being distracted by a well-meaning
audience member
shoving dollar bills in her belt despite
the risks
few sword swallowers even those who end
up needing serious surgery
die for their art the sword swallowers
association international reports only
knowing
of 29 people worldwide who've died
during the act since 1880
though they do admit that the real
number is probably much higher
surprisingly many sword swallowers are
self-taught
often as teenagers but what goddamn
teenagers are sitting in their bedrooms
whilst their parents are cozley and
scones downstairs watching telly
thinking that attempting to shove a
sword down their throat
seems anything like a good idea perhaps
it's the lore of joining an ancient
tradition because sword swallowing is
nothing new
the first were found in india four
thousand
years ago for those early pioneers
it was a religious act carried out by
hindu shamans
and islamic fakirs in order to
demonstrate their
apparent invulnerability and connection
with the gods
around the same time they also developed
snake handling
and walking on hot coals just in case
the gods didn't think
knocking back a sword was badass enough
one
particular tribe in the southern indian
state of andhra pradesh
known as the kunda dora have passed the
art of sword swallowing down
from father to son for generations
and they still do to this very day can
you imagine that
are we going to play football again
today daddy no
today son we're going to ram a sword
down your throat instead
from these tribal roots sword swallowing
went on
to spread across the world though to be
fair it took a while
in the 1st century a.d 2 000
years after those first indian
practitioners it could be found on the
streets
and in the festivals of ancient greece
and rome
greeks and romans are known to have
traded with india swapping wine and
precious metals
for spices ivory and silk so perhaps the
first greek sword swallower
was a trader who enthralled by the
performances he saw
decided to have a go himself around the
8th century a.d
sword swallowing began to pop up in
china and then in japan
where it morphed into an acrobatic
street art
called sarugaku which combines sword
swallowing with
juggling miming and dancing in the
middle east in the 12th century sword
swallowing went back to its roots
as a spiritual practice and was adopted
by the mysterious
dervishers dervishes are a devout order
who believe the best way to connect with
god is through experiences
and what better experience could there
be in life
than adorning a huge skirt and whirling
around
whilst painfully resisting the urge to
vomit but it turns out
whirling dervishes also have a long
tradition
of sword swallowing walking on hot
coals and eating glass
though presumably not at the same time
as all the whirling
as the tradition moved through europe
religion
and sword swallowing didn't always get
along quite so well
with the medieval catholic church and
its holy inquisitions
condemning it as a heretical practice
the prospect of being tortured as a
heretic did put off
some sword swallowers but not all
i guess you could say they're not a
particularly risk-averse bunch
sword swallowing was seen across europe
in the medieval period as a popular
street art
performed by wandering entertainers
alongside more
ordinary acts such as juggling singing
and mime
the tradition began to die out in europe
after the middle ages
but it never truly disappeared it was
performed by buskers
on the streets of victorian london and
then
in late 19th century america a
sword-swallowing renaissance occurred
after the world's colombian exposition
in chicago in 1893
visited by 27.3 million people
it featured a sword swallowing display
that quickly caught the public's
imagination
after which it became a regular feature
of travelling sideshows
and circuses across america as
public interest grew so did the risks
sword swallowers began experimenting
with multiple swords
and even neon tubes by the way you
really don't want one of those to
explode inside of you edna price born in
niece of a veteran sword swallower and
friend of harry houdini
was known as the queen of sword
swallowers
she once swallowed 12 swords in one go
and then moved on to neon tubes that was
so bright her audience could see them
glowing
through her throat in the 1930s she was
a regular at the famous ripley's believe
it or not
auditorium in new york which you can
still visit in times square today
edna lived until she was 88 so clearly
the sword and tube swallowing
did her no permanent damage francis
doran
a veteran sword swallower born in 1908
who spent decades working travelling
sideshows
and circuses was not so lucky
in 1969 in houston a neon tube
exploded in his throat in front of an
audience of 200
releasing gas and shattered glass inside
his body
the tube was removed but francis was
never the same again
he died ten years later from pneumonia
caused by the injuries
and then there was hannibal helmorto a
german
tax inspector turned sword swallower who
tore a four-inch hole in his esophagus
while swallowing a neon tube in 12012
he spent several weeks in hospital
unable to speak
and was fed directly into his stomach
amazingly
hannibal returned albeit nervously to
his profession
and decided he didn't quite come close
enough to death last time
because he added swallowing hedge
clippers
and drill blades to his performance
if you want to have a go yourself which
you definitely shouldn't
ever like seriously
there are some major biological hurdles
you'll have to overcome
the irony of sword swallowing is that it
doesn't actually involve
any swallowing at all in fact
swallowing is the last thing you want to
do when a sword is lodged in your throat
the goal is to relax your throat muscles
not
activate them the first step is to
carefully align the sword with a muscle
called the upper esophageal sphincter
which sits in the middle of your throat
just behind your adam's apple
you then need to tip your head far back
to reduce the bends in your throat
making it as straight and in line with
your esophagus as possible
giving the sword a relatively safe
passage down
and whilst you're doing this you need to
stay completely relaxed
yeah good luck with that one your
biggest obstacle will be fighting
against your body's natural gag reflex
the last thing you want to do when
you're half a sword down
is vomit for some it takes years to
overcome this powerful inbuilt defense
and many people never can if you manage
all
the sword moves between your lungs
perilously close to your heart
sword swallowers are known to brush
their heart during the act
and for some people the blade actually
pushes the heart
a couple of centimeters to the side
during its passage
yeah then the blade will pass the liver
before finally
settling deep down in the stomach that
is thankfully as far as you can go
without killing yourself none of these
organs are naturally in a straight line
performers line up their body in such a
way that the sword has a relatively easy
route into the stomach
which involves a few contortions a lot
of concentration
and a little bit of nudging your vital
organs gently out of the way
as swallowers reports that they are
constantly aware of
every vital organ and its exact position
in fact they must learn to feel this
connection to prevent
internal injuries some swallowers use
lubrication
but others go completely unnatural
so do you still fancy your chances yeah
i didn't think so despite its medical
risks
sword swallowing has proved rather
useful to our understanding of the human
body
over the years in 1868 in freiburg
germany a local doctor was so impressed
by the performance of a visiting sword
swallower
he examines the man's esophagus with a
mirror
hoping to see exactly how he was able to
so easily relax all his
internal squishy bits that us
non-masochists
don't have any conscious control over he
knew that if the sword swallower could
swallow a sword
he could swallow an endoscope tube he
became the subject of the world's first
successful esophagoscopy when another
local doctor adolf cusmell
asked him to swallow a primitive
endoscope which he used to examine his
insides with the aid of a mirror
and an oil lamp though despite these
early achievements it wasn't until the
invention of the electric
light that endoscopies really took off
sword swallowing has also been used to
study digestion
one 19th century scottish doctor
convinced a sword swallower
to ingest metal tubes with holes in them
in which he'd placed pieces of meat
he then asked the participant to
retrieve the tubes
one by one at intervals
allowing him to examine the relative
levels of digestion
as time passes inside the body even as
recently as 2007
die andrews a four-time world record
holding sword swallower
used his unique ability to help
researchers at johns hopkins university
studying new techniques to aid patients
recovering from severe throat injuries
unsurprisingly the professional sword
swallowing club
has a rather exclusive membership the
sword swallowers association
international
says there are just a few dozen working
today
worldwide though they don't say how many
amateurs are assets
it's estimated that learning the craft
takes three to seven years
and mastering it another five
even for the most experienced pros it
never gets easy
the gag reflex can be managed but it
doesn't disappear with
any amount of practice that calm-looking
demeanor you see on stage
is a well-rehearsed facade to hide their
watering guys and a desire to wretch
veteran sword swallowers sometimes end
up with problems swallowing
severe acid reflux or even esophageal
cancer
as a result of constantly bringing
stomach acid up along with their swords
unlike almost every other professional
body in the world
the sword swallowers association don't
recommend that
anyone ever becomes a sword swallower
describing their own work
as extremely dangerous you know what
i think i have to agree so on that note
i think i should end by simply saying
don't try this at home
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks